le lamantin 40000 habitants 62
kilomètres carrés de superficie et 70
quartiers un bien vaste territoire
lorsque survient une catastrophe
naturelle quartier palmistes ce matin la
ville tente de recruter des réservistes
les bénévoles qui servent de relais sur
le terrain auprès des autorités lorsque
les populations sont en détresse
on a par le passé eu des quartiers
complètement coupé où on pouvait pas
accéder et même dernièrement avec les
puits qu'il ya eu au mois de mai on a eu
le quartier sao duchesne complètement
coupées donc nous avons l'habitude et
c'est pour ça que nous nous préparons à
ne pas voir se risquent à nouveau se
lamente un compte soixante dix
réservistes
il en faudrait 700 au moins 10 par
quartier ceux-ci signer un contrat avec
la ville et la ville une convention avec
leur employeur
les réservistes sont formés pour assurer
la logistique dans leur quartier avant
l'arrivée des secours
nous sommes en capacité de monter des
villages de tentes des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence
avec un accueil en hébergement c'est à
dire donner aux gens la capacité de
dormir
la capacité d'être nourri d'avoir un
accueil psychologique et vous êtes formé
justement à tous ces détails
oui nous ont formés à tous ces détails
alors nous sommes essentiellement formé
le soir en mairie pour la partie
théorique et en pratique nous sommes
formés sur le terrain par des exercices
dans lesquels on a des impliqués des
plats sont contents qu'on en change
comme s'il y avait une vraie catastrophe
pour être efficace le moment venu et
réservistes ont pour mission de repérer
les personnes les plus fragiles dans le
quartier la motivation à rejoindre la
réserve bien souvent d'une expérience
personnelle
il est inondable
il ya beaucoup de personnes
vieillissantes donc nous sommes beaucoup
difficultés entre les inondations autour
de chez eux de monter leurs meubles ou
autres
c'est ça ils sont et une mission d'aider
vos voisins oui exactement
ce sens hommes en gris effet il faut il
faut il faut il a besoin d' aide
on a besoin de ce coup on a besoin de ce
doux ni ne peut pas rester chez soi
venus écouter et puis après alors il
faut vraiment s'engager se donne et se
donner un attrait dans l'action les
volontaires de tout âge et de toute
condition trouvent naturellement leur
place dans ce dispositif
quant aux communes ce moyen je n'ai pas
encore vraiment opérationnel la mise en
place de réserves communales sur le
territoire est un souhait de l'état qui
pourtant n'accorde aucun financement
local